rated teen
hi I'm Peter and I'm the game director
Brad not hi I'm a no and I'm a designer
on red not dreadnought is an upcoming
free to play area llamada action game
that focuses on big spaceship battles
contains five classes and each class
contains multiple ships each ship has a
fully customizable set of weapons and
abilities the game mode we will be
playing today is team deathmatch and
we'll start off by showing you a
completely new ship which is the arcon
dreadnought the icon is one of the
lighter dreadnought classes so it's
faster can take a little less damage but
this particular loader that we have it
comes equipped with plenty of offensive
stuff and armor hardeners which actually
help you survive as well it's a quite
aggressive layout and we're using it now
putting the energy to our engines to
engage into a fight with another account
that's being supported by a tactical but
it seems like this is actually too late
with our cover coming in and we take it
down quite easily
we also lower the net janitors threat
not into the pit and we had a really
nice position here positioning also
helps to use the broadside activating
the hardness to take more damage and a
tactically cruiser actually came in here
to support us in the fight a very nice
positioning drawing fire onto us while
the technique is using the beam
amplifier and now turning around be
members often finishing it off with a
nice broadside strike it was a really
unfortunate move from that and it goes
down activating the auditors to take
some down some of the smaller fighter
jets while our technical is actually
refilling our energy is so that we are
ready to get back into the fight
and now that our health is full we are
ready to go again here we try to get
take down the Corvette with the
broadside unfortunately it's a bit too
fast and we miss it best was scouting
ahead to actually make the way for the
feet that's coming in home to behind so
there's a threat not a destroyer class
and a good life to Peter actually now
hit the class taking almost down the
great Lobby finished it off and I'll be
in a pretty good spot to actually take
down the destroyer as well it looks
really good except now there's a
Corvette coming be hard beneath us and
it fired torpedoes it seems really bad I
think we're going down as well that we
took down he found the destroyer
beforehand so I'm still quite a nice
betting match here where we took out two
enemy ships but we went down as one and
we jump back in with the technique loser
the tactical Cruiser takes on a role of
supporting supporting team and there's a
technical nuke that just came in taking
out here to lose and if we were just so
and really heard as well as well but the
tactical cruisers abilities come really
handy you can see that we're repairing
ourselves and now getting ready to
repair everyone else rock careful
there's a threat not jumping into our
side so you can see the exit of the gate
and he had actually come so we'd better
make our way back to our dreadnought and
support that and fight against this but
not the positioning is really important
in dreadnought and now this third node
is actually in a pretty bad spot it's
completely separated from its team and
our team is gathering around it while
all dreadnought is being supported and
being repaired also we'll have to Peter
that the enemies in just one I didn't do
too much damage to us but there's a
Corvette coming in trying to actually
take us out and even yards in the fight
against the other fight here you could
see the flat dreadnought using flak
cannons against the Corvette really
heard it forced it to run away yeah and
actually there's a really nice job in
scaring off the cadets and
teamplay here we are keeping the
Dreadnought alive and it's actually
keeping away the faster and tough
enemies for the tackle through their way
as well yes like I said before this
dread nose is really stranded it's
struggling to get away but energy is
almost down it's trying to use and now
it's your ability using its warp drive
but I think it's too late yes here it
goes time we're using the repair turrets
to support our death not there's a
destroyer coming here if dropping below
the clutter but that is - I used to live
Tokyo and was too close so it actually
went down as well but it also took us
out so we're jumping back to the battle
with the Thanatos class threat not the
Thanatos is the heaviest of our
dreadknots and it's a particularly good
choice because we are bit behind on the
score so we want to some want something
with high survivability at this point
yeah and the battle is raging on right
in front of us here so we are making our
way over waiting for the warp drive
ability to actually be active as you can
see as the icons coming up above the
ships over there there's a formation of
enemy ships and now the green icon
indicates that our tactical nuke is
actually ready since there's a formation
over there that we want to break up
using the tactical and now the warp
drive a jump over to this dreadnought
over there while firing our missiles at
the center coming in we engage with our
black hands and turn on the heavier auto
turrets doing quite a lot of damage the
fire cannons are really efficient close
range even against current here really
nice the other dreadnought use its
missiles but exactly at the right moment
we pulled up our shields so the damage
that we took on this is actually quite
low and we're in a really good position
to win this fight this is why the
dread-nots is now using the whatever the
diffusive jump out of it but doesn't
make a difference because unfortunately
we lost this match so thank you for
watching thank you